dayton hypernova has a couple new videos
mike
and um and so this this is an
ongoing story arc so um
you know he's talking about his 3d
camera well in this video he's recording
himself
asking his bigot father to drive him to
the hardware store for his 3d camera
ready i'm sorry before you hit play sure
who is purchasing cameras at a hardware
store in 2020.
kid paradoxes it's very odd to me here
we go
oh remember he keeps his camera in a bag
of sun chips you have to that might be
the tripod
by the way this isn't a dayton hypernova
video this is actually a um
[Music]
this is a new video game that a couple
people have been developing
this is a cocaine simulator oh nice 20
20. i like it
where you actually play as the cocaine
yeah oh cool so most of the game is just
you're sitting in a bag
right or up johnny depp's notices i was
very inspired by
the cocaine the bring to the trailer
daily um
but yeah it's literally you in a pocket
crinkle crinkle of like [ __ ]
of plastic and you just here
i know the guy who owns this place he
lets us go upstairs sometimes
the last level is uh you're on the floor
of a bathroom public bathroom
just go up into a straw in somebody's
nose
um
um i was wondering
um i was wondering if you could drive me
to like the hardware store and see if i
could find any of those
finding little controlled said
screwdrivers
and i know i ordered some online but if
i could get them sooner that's really
good
so you ordered them online but now
you're gonna go buy other ones
because [ __ ] it right just waste your
parents money i also love how
this i hate this is what i hate about
him he tortures these poor people
but then he always does this like like
he'll go up to him and act like nothing
happened
and he's just like hey so check it out
like i was just wondering like hey
whenever you can
like maybe hook me up with a ride maybe
in the hardware store cause i gotta
totally get this stuff and it's like
you just screamed at and hit your mother
the other day
and then you come down like hey guys i
need some health burritos
i need to use your car and it's like
what
i mean sometimes it's tough
[Applause]
his dad said he was going to take him
and he goes i got to get ready first to
go to the hardware store
[Music]
yeah how dulled up the psoriasis boy
have to be to go to the hardware store
yeah put on your nicest sundress so we
could get out of here if you saw the
unconscionable condition that i walk
into the 7-eleven by my house some
nights
it's not like we're we're talking
[ __ ]
a pair of basketball shorts that you can
see my dick and balls through and like a
[ __ ]
and a hoodie or a tank top because i
need cigarettes or something
and this one has to get all dolled up
and it's like somebody else is giving
you a ride on top of it oh i hate this
[ __ ]
you should be ready when you ask for a
ride right exactly you should be right
you should be ready to go
actually i have a picture of i have a
picture of marsh
when he is at a 7-eleven um
he's me dick out everybody dig out and
everything that's so gee
i'm sorry sorry my penis was out
all right we continued
i mean i'm going to be here all day
sometime today or tomorrow
[Music]
sometime today or tomorrow the dad's
willing to take him right now but he's
not ready to go
[Music]
you need a shower before you go to a
hardware store are you planning on
getting your [ __ ] on in the hardware
store
[Music]
well i'm saying it to explain how long
it takes to get ready i
shower and then i brush it down he's got
a shower and lotion down before he goes
to the hardware store
i'm going to probably go to bed about my
car
yeah all right that would my first
follow-up question would be if somebody
goes like yeah we gotta go to the
hardware store but i'm gonna have to
probably shower and lotion down
i'd be like are you getting your dick
sucked in the hardware store
if the answer is no let's just go to the
hardware store get this done please like
let's just get this over
unless you're trying to [ __ ] the gut the
old man at the hardware store
between now and nine can you get a
shower
it's not just a shower i think that's
why i just said well then you can't
get them nine o'clock
[Music]
every video like this she's gonna want
to get pneumonia
every single day in hypernova video is
is
these people trying to work with him
and being way nicer than i don't think i
could ever be
and it's still never good enough and
it's still everything always gets [ __ ]
up with this guy and it's like
literally i and honestly i almost feel
like
and i'll be completely honest with you
he got the video already ready
i don't think he even wanted her i think
he wants to film an altercation yeah i
think you're right all he wants so he
gets the camera ready
he goes down there and he goes i'm going
to ask if he can get to the hardware
store and then i bet he's going to let
my racist
skinhead brother beat me in this house
or whatever the [ __ ] he does
and then he goes down there and he calls
this bluff and he's like i was just
wondering if i i could get a ride maybe
to the hardware store and he's just like
okay sure you ready now
because we can go right now but i got to
get it done because i got to get right
back and it's like oh well
i was maybe later i was going to lotion
up first
[ __ ] man i'm trying to avoid getting
pneumonia outside i have to shower and
then motion down and it takes
if it was a simple shower and i'd get
out of here in an hour but uh
an hour an a a shower a
simple shower takes you an hour
i'm gonna tell you right and by the way
obviously like if you take a real shower
you're gonna take longer but let's say
like
you know i slept i wake up and like
you're banging on my door and you're
like hey we said we're gonna go to
tampa or whatever get ready right now my
answer would be
oh [ __ ] i overslept give me like 15
minutes i'll be ready i could you know
what i mean like a guy should
yeah of course in the shower
armpits [ __ ] crotching teeth and
you're done throw your hands
out hey man sorry i always let's get out
of here let's go let's move
an hour for if it was a simple shower i
mean you know an hour maybe
and you're like what after i shower or
my whole body floats
[Music]
and then this has to be also
contributing to why your [ __ ] skin is
so [ __ ] up
you dumb showers too much i don't even
have psoriasis but if i took
hour-long showers every day yet but if i
took hour long no you're thinking of
cirrhosis
oh sorry i confuse them yeah i don't
have psoriasis
which um but yeah like if i took an
hour-long shower every day because i
like a hot shower like i've always been
a
like i like my skin turning right i just
like a hot shower
and uh if i took an hour long shower
every day
i would have skin like dayton hypernova
like i would be going
i don't understand it why am i flaking
and it's like
i don't know because you're in a red hot
shower drying out your skin for a
[ __ ]
hour like all the whole point of a
shower is not to overdo it it's not to
overdo anything you're not supposed to
overdo it with shampoo you're not
supposed to overdo it with soap you're
not supposed to overdo it with condoms
with condoms well not do it at all but
it's like everything you're rubbing on
your body is basically like
a deodorized industrial solvent anyway
so it's not good for you but
you know a shower is supposed to be get
your [ __ ] your crevices and [ __ ]
clean
chuck on a little deodorant hey oh
you're good to go it doesn't need to be
a whole process
the shower itself is now yes now how
long will it take for your body to get
ready
[Music]
so why don't you just go ahead and do it
[Music]
i don't think i'm ready to take a shower
yet you're the one
asking for the favor well i don't know
what you're gonna do
all i'm saying is
i don't know what time the hardware
store goes yeah i don't know yet this is
why it's either today or tomorrow
you know listen i i come from a uh land
down under
um nailed it i do come from uh
a certain very culturally enriched
socioeconomic background so
i'm used to being around other poors and
you know dayton for somebody who's poor
he sure is very bougie
and it's like poor people there's
there's an unspoken rule of like
you know people especially poor
neighborhoods is always like a neighbor
that's like hey man yo
give me a ride real quick i just gotta
run up pick up my paycheck or something
and the rule is you go all right but we
got to go right now
and the etiquette is always [ __ ] okay
cool let me
let me just go grab a while and we'll go
boom done thank you that's it you say
thank you and you go
this whole thing he makes i'm telling
you i really am convinced he didn't even
want to ride
he wanted to fight with his dad this is
what this [ __ ] guy does he does he
sets these up he wouldn't had a camera
waiting so he could ask for a ride so
his dad could say yes
he was waiting for a well why can't you
take the dang bus
and then it was going to be a whole
thing and he was going to be like hey my
brother beats me
could be a problem it will be it could
be i don't
know is there something on their mind
yes
[Music]
let me know okay will you be straight
with me if i'm interested with you
because that's fair
over hearing a program about morality
[Music]
let's stop let's start over because
let's go go back to the beginning
where we are i have
nothing that is in my way tomorrow
donna you gotta wait you're
well is she moral or immoral i don't
understand dad listen
you don't understand this is a draw this
is driving to the hardware store what is
being
morality doesn't matter in this
situation
you know the irony is that half of his
problems would probably be fixed
that's the reasoning
[Music]
i have a life and he goes i want to know
what that means
it means it's none of your [ __ ]
business you're the one asking for
things
i want to know specifically what you're
doing considering you're asking him for
the favor
that's that's the best part hey royce
can you give me a ride to the hardware
store
hey man i can't tomorrow i'm i'm kind of
busy what are you doing why
what's the problem i don't think that's
any of your business i'm just
no i'm not able to i have to yeah so
like obviously you're too busy to take
me hardware store why what are you doing
you can't tell me but you're asking for
the favor i'm a moral person
what i can't imagine living with this
person it's exhausting
[Music]
this conversation should have been two
minutes long hey can i get a ride to the
hardware store
sure but you got to be ready now ah [ __ ]
you know what it's gonna take me four
hours to take a shower but i'll tell you
what
can we do it tomorrow i could try my
best but i really have things i got to
do tomorrow
hey you know what i get it it's
christmas time [ __ ] crazy out there
but hey maybe i'll i'll ask you again
tomorrow maybe we can work something out
so here's how it should go watch but
okay now i'll do it tell me i can't go
hey can you give me a ride at the
hardware store tomorrow i mean it
depends
i've got stuff going on i don't worry
about them i'll just uber it's no big
deal i tried if you're going out anyway
that's how it should go i just figured
i'd save a few bucks on the yeah
but you know what i thought you were
going out anyway but if you're not it's
not a big deal it's like five bucks
i'll go i'll take a number no problem
thanks that's it it's over it's [ __ ]
over i mean and then you know what
dayton to you know you know it's like
it's not enough to just drive him to the
spot
you know that he's gonna make you sit in
the car he's gonna be [ __ ] an hour
in the stores and he's gonna want to
make sure the heater runs at full blast
because he gets cold because his bird
bones
he's so hateable everything's about mr
complacent but i'm asking for a straight
answer
i gave you a straight answer but your
ears are crooked
what's wrong you're the straight answer
i'm asking you know what the big deal is
about uh going to harvard
tomorrow not tomorrow today no i'm
asking about tomorrow okay
i'm telling you that i also have a life
i want to know
today i don't have anything to do
tomorrow i got
lots of stuff to do what is he hiding
about small specific oh
dear god what is he hiding about
tomorrow for those who don't know dayton
there's a whole lore you can look them
up we have clips everywhere
but my point is the lore on dayton is
insane right he lives there for free
okay
they not only for free they pay him a
hundred dollars to do their laundry
and he accuses them of beating him and
his brother being a white supremacist
i want you tomorrow to get up
at 5 30 with me listen
get up with 5 30 and you stay with me
the whole time
until wait a minute because what is this
help me out with what i have to do
tomorrow
i need to even have a communication all
about what's going on in order to even
be able to agree with that
so you tell me okay what's going on
about today and i'll tell you about i
told you there was only a problem today
i already told you here we go
no that's not the only problem the
shower's not a problem
you've got to dry off so you can go
outside to not get pneumonia oh
listen i don't want to have that
attitude with you i want to have
straight conversations
yeah i doubt the dad looks like somebody
who has [ __ ] a tool kit
i've seen that hoarder house yeah before
there's a screwdriver in there
tomorrow if i have a wall of our
screwdriver we already had that
conversation yesterday
so what kind of stuff do you need i
don't have a specific name for it i know
the size though is smaller than any of
the available ones
they are going to ask you that at the
heart i will be fine with them as
you know but you're not going to have
the expertise of me any better
i'm going to tell them with that in my
hand
that thing that you provided that the
only size that fits that
is not a phillips head and i need a
phillips head therefore they will know
and you are not going to help me any
faster than them on that information
what if they tell you we don't have
[Music]
i just said i know
what fits based on the size of the one
that doesn't have the right head on it
so you're going to take that thing
yes it's very obvious mom it's very
simple
because he is a smart app
i want to know why i can't go
[Applause]
that statement's exactly what you were
saying mike he is
looking he is looking for a fight he is
looking to fight with people that's what
he's doing
he can't do that because this is about
simple stuff dad yes why are you
why can't you go to the hardware store
today the only reason i
might not be able to is because i need
to shower before i go anywhere
that takes go take a shower
also the amount of time he spent arguing
he could have been showering yeah
i could have taken three showers by now
and walked to the hardware store in the
time they've been fighting
tell me why do you need a doctor or i'm
going to do
that five
four three four
this might be my new favorite video
there it is
and a video he's like gandalf end of
video
right there that man is a powerful
[ __ ] this might be my favorite one
right
it's the best it really just picks it's
even better than the old fight because
this one
just keeps going and going well you know
why it's killing each other but the
reason it's better than the old fight
is that this they're always petty
obviously but this is the
silliest one in terms of what the fight
is about
yeah but it's so clear that that this is
all put on by dayton
to [ __ ] create a scene
i hate him he's so exhausted